is russia helping china build nuclear
weapons or give them any supplies they
have been the the the uh the whole and
this is one of the thing reasons i think
we'd be able to do a deal with putin
because i think he's russia
not just putin
they're probably disappointed in uh in
in
and what they've gotten back from china
because uh china went from
pretty much a militarily backward
country you know that we weren't all
that concerned about
but in a couple of decades they've been
built into a pure competitor with the
united states both with conventional
forces
modern navy modern army modern air force
and now they've got
you know modern nuclear weapon systems
and all of this has been built
on technology that's been stolen from
the united states but also technology
that they've gotten from russia in fact
some of the most important stuff is
russian supply technology for both
conventional and nuclear forces a great
example is that is the new icbm the
df-41 icbm
which is uh you know a moved icbm middle
carry 10 war it looks a lot like
russia's ss18 in terms of being a mirved
warhead it's a first strike weapon
highly accurate but unlike the ss18 it's
mobile it's actually a mobile missile
which makes it even better for surprise
attack and that's all built on russian
technology
and uh
the russians have got some things back
from the strategic partnership but
uh the relationship has been
disproportionately beneficial to china
you know the chinese have been cheap
partners you know they have
what
russia has built them into a world-class
competitor that could
arguably win world war iii against the
united states and russia has you know
the economic benefits they've gotten
from that relationship
are are uh you know not nearly as
impressive as i i think as the russians
would like and they know that these
capabilities will eventually be turned
against themselves
pbd how are you processing i mean let me
just recap what he just said and maybe i
got
you just went from world war iii
potentially russia with china as an ally
taking out united states the west and
then somehow got right from there to
already world war iv
russia versus china the remnants of who
wins that
i got that part and then initially
before that we talked about globalism
and
pat initiated the entire conversation
with what's changed since three weeks
ago while the world economic forum was
just held in davos switzerland
uh if there's anything that that i took
from that is that the eu
is getting closer and stronger they used
to be called the
the russian house in davos they changed
the name to the russian war crimes house
located in davos i don't know if we have
that picture
but it seems like eu is getting stronger
um
united states obviously proxy war with
eu
ukraine world war three boom world war
four is already happening there's the
russian war crimes house
i'm just kind of processing all that how
are you what's your biggest takeaway so
far we spent almost four hours
you said something last time on last
time's uh podcast with
uh dr pry is you said
you know the difference between america
and some of these countries is we don't
have to worry about who's on our border
we don't want mexico and what is it
canada what do we got to worry about by
the way did you you hear about canada's
story yesterday what
justin trudeau just announced the
difference is
imagine if us
was border to china
and china keeps getting stronger and
stronger and stronger what do you think
world war four is going to be probably
u.s china so
what he's saying is not that out of uh
but he's saying world war four would be
russia china i know i agree but i tell
you what i'm more concerned about is
is if u.s if if you world war 4
is
china and russia against everybody
that's what you really got to worry
about i'm it's totally it's a much
better situation if world war 4 is china
against russia
you don't want world war iv to be china
and russia against
everybody else you don't want that you
want those two guys to
if they're gonna if there's gonna be a
war that that's better to be them to
than anybody else
them united against everybody else but
what are we worried about mexico i mean
what's going on with mexico who you
worried about colombia what were you
worried about argentina brazil canada
you think justin trudeau
you know with his aggressive stand he
took yesterday to freeze gun sales we
are capping the number of handguns in
this country
right and what he announced i don't know
if you saw what he know did you watch
the video yesterday what he announced
the fact that
he stood up there with 20 men standing
behind him with masks on
uh extremely responsible people and
you know what we're going to do is take
guns away from people like
the the the angle he's taken do you
worry about him attacking you no
what he's doing is in america sits there
and says okay you guys just got weaker
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]